they love this piggy dolly parton and
women that kind of lived outside the
standards of beauty add one more name to
test holidays list of inspiring women
supermodel Gisele Bundchen you look good
on Tuesday the 31 year old plus-size
model posted this photo to Instagram
breastfeeding her newborn son Bowie
before a photo shoot if the pic looks
familiar that's because it is a total
nod to a photo Gisele shared in December
2013
tez explained in the caption quote it
reminded me of Giselle's iconic photo
breastfeeding on set working moms come
in all shapes sizes colors and creeds
hashtag normalized breastfeeding besides
breastfeeding the brunette beauty has
also been very vocal about body shaming
here's what she told ET in May people
picked on me in school but it's entirely
different when you open yourself up to
the world and people are commenting and
you're thinking to yourself like what
you're saying is not true at all I Know
Who I am I know my body it really gets
to you but you just have to remember
that those people are just miserable
you